this elephant you can see is absolutely
focused on that runner his trunks
outstretched his is crumpled up his ears
he's not trying to chase this rhino or
intimidated he is trying to catch it and
indeed once he caught that animal and
killed it once the elephant has caught
the rhino he Gore's it from above
straight into the shoulder blade just
pushing his tusks deep into the
shoulders and and breaking the back in
the palace the elephant then uses the
weight of its head to crush the Rhino
while driving its tusks through the body
the cause of death is clear and Van Dyck
has a definite indication that the
attack is intentional but a bigger
question remains is this a single rogue
animal that is somehow managed to escape
detection or is it something deeper
affecting more than just one individual
elephant in Amboseli National Park in
Kenya elephant project manager soilless
il L is trying to narrow down the
suspects she has recorded 185 more
cattle deaths since 1997
and collected dozens of eyewitness
statements anywhere else picking the
culprit out of a lineup of more than
1400 elephants would be difficult but
amble celli's elephants are among the
most studied in the world
since 1972 the Amboseli Trust for
Elephants has monitored the populations
behavior assembling identification
records for each and every one of them
we have one thousand four hundred and
fifty elephants and all the elephants
are known it virtually Sai ll attempts
to match the photo IDs with the
descriptions for my witnesses in pill
ensberg Gus Van Dyke is collating
forensic photographs from the new Rhino
deaths he identifies something they all
have in common at every crime scene
there is just one set of elephant prints
but the prints differ from kill to kill
only males travel alone but the
footprints aren't big enough to belong
to an adult these are teenagers old
enough to have left the herd but not yet
fully grown the implications are
enormous van Dyck isn't looking for one
killer there are lots of them in Kenya
the pattern is a very different one all
the attacks here involve families of
elephants
siyul el suspects appear to be mature
females
you